hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
here at google cloud
and in this video i want to show you how
you can use migrate for anthos
to migrate ibm websphere applications to
containers
in just a few clicks we'll start by
looking at the system requirements then
i'll provide a quick
overview of the migration process then
we'll jump into an actual migration
now this video is part of a series on
migrate for anthos so if you haven't
checked out those first videos in the
series
you might want to go back and watch
those as this video builds on them
you can find the link in the description
[Music]
before we get started i wanted to
clarify that in this video i'm
discussing
the migration of traditional ibm
websphere application server
and ibm websphere application server
network deployment applications
rather than ibm websphere liberty apps
keep that
distinction in mind when you hear me say
websphere application server
migrate4anthos lets you modernize app
workloads running on websphere
application servers by converting them
to application containers
you can then deploy the app containers
to gke or anthos clusters
on google cloud and those clusters on
vmware
and anthos clusters on aws
a websphere application server vm can
contain multiple apps
migrate for anthos helps you automate
the modernization of websphere
application server apps to containers by
discovering deployed apps
in the source vm and automatically
suggesting the configuration for the
modernization
with migrate for anthocys you migrate
each app to its own container
this allows you to test and deploy the
migrated apps individually
rather than having to test and deploy
multiple apps together
regardless of whether or not your source
apps were running websphere application
server or web sphere application server
network deployment
the resulting container image will be
the official
ibm websphere application server
traditional container image
and for those of you wondering the
original responsibilities of network
deployment
clustering scheduling version rollouts
request routing etc
will now be offloaded to kubernetes
migrate for antho supports the migration
of apps hosted on the following versions
of ibm webster application server
websphere applications server
traditional 8.5.5.x and websphere
application server traditional 9.0.5.x
migrate for anthos extracts two types of
configurations from the vm
the configuration for each application
and the configuration of the target
profile which defines the runtime
environment
of a websphere application server
including ports
the java virtual machine settings etc
the migrate for antho software automates
the use of the ibm websphere
application server migration toolkit for
application binaries
to discover assess and generate
migration reports as well as creating
configuration scripts
before you can start a migration you
must upload the toolkit to a google
cloud storage bucket in your account
check the documentation for more
information on this procedure
when migrating websphere application
server apps the processing cluster can
be deployed on google kubernetes engine
or an anthos cluster on google cloud
vmware or aws
regardless of where the cluster runs it
must use a cloud storage bucket as the
repository
for the resulting migration artifacts
for more information on creating a
processing cluster check out the first
video in this series
you can find a link in the description
below
and be sure to read the docs to get the
full details on all the system
requirements
with the prerequisites out of the way
let's take a look at the general
migration flow
first you're going to add a migration
source which represents the source
platform from which you will be
migrating
then you're going to create the
migration and that specifies the vm
you're actually going to migrate
you'll edit your migration plan
including selecting the websphere
application server app that you want to
migrate
and you should migrate one websphere
application server app
per migration then you're going to
actually perform the migration to
generate the app container artifacts and
then review those artifacts in
preparation for building the deployable
app image
now use the migrated artifacts to build
the container
for your migrated app and then deploy
your migrated app to your target cluster
finally test the migrated app and
validate the migration
note that if your source vm has multiple
apps you're going to need to repeat
steps 3 through 7 for each application
you wish to migrate
also you may have noticed if you've
watched previous videos there's not an
explicit step to assess the application
using the discovery tool that's because
the assessment happens when you run
the migration all right let's go ahead
and jump into an actual migration
we're going to take a source vm and
extract a single application from that
vm
then deploy it to a gke cluster
following the basic flow that i just
outlined as you can see in the cloud
console i've actually already
created my migration processing cluster
and my migration source
i've also gone in and i've stopped my
websphere vm
with those things out of the way i'm all
ready to start by creating the actual
migration and to do that
i'll move into the cloud shell and issue
the mig ctl
create command most of these parameters
are pretty straightforward but i wanted
to point out this app
type property at the bottom that's where
we specify that we're actually migrating
a websphere application
creating the migration is going to take
a few minutes so i'm going to pause the
video and i'll come back when it's done
with the migration assessment completed
i wanted to show you the application
discovery report that was generated
it's stored up in a cloud storage bucket
so let's navigate to the actual report
and load it up
now i'm not going to go through the
report in detail i just want you to know
that it's available to you
and it will give you a bunch of
information on the applications that
were scanned
let's move back into cloud shell and i
need to download and edit my
migration.yaml so i'll use mig ctl
get migration and then i'm going to go
in and edit that file and here are these
path
variables now they represent the
applications that were found during the
scanning process and i only need one of
them you only migrate one application at
a time
so i'm going to delete this query.ear
path location here
and then the other thing i want to do is
i want to go down
to the default app name and change that
from websphere to something else
so i'll make that change here and i'll
actually make the change
for the name of the docker image that's
created as well
we use mig-ctl to upload our updated
migration plan so that when we execute
the migration in the next step
these new settings are used and so let's
go ahead and do that
i'll clear the screen and then i'm going
to use mig-ctl to execute the migration
plan and generate my migration artifacts
this will take a few minutes so i'm
going to pause the video and i'll rejoin
when it's done
make ctls finish so let's go ahead and
grab those artifacts using mig ctl get
artifacts
i will list out the directory so you can
see which was created we've got a docker
file
our applications ear file and this ws
admin dot py file this is where a bunch
of settings for your application will be
held and you may need to edit that
depending on your application
finally there's a build script that
automates the creation of our docker
image and uploads it to the container
registry
i'll go ahead and execute our build
script the build
file takes several minutes to run i've
sped up the video so you can see what's
happening in the background
it's going to pull the base docker image
then it runs through the configuration
of the websphere server including
copying in the application
and then finally it pushes that
completed container image up into the
registry
now i'm going to go ahead and edit the
deployment.yaml file which by default
provides a headless cluster ip service
which is only accessible from within the
cluster
i'm going to change that to type load
balancer so we can access our service
externally
all that's left to do now is to actually
deploy the application and we'll do that
using
kubectl apply minus f deployment
spec.yaml
that's going to deploy that deployment
spec we just looked at so we're going to
create a service we're going to create a
deployment
and then we can check the status of
those by using kubectl get pods
and kubectl get service now from the
service we can grab the external ip
address here
and see that our application a movie
rental service
is up and running in our web browser and
that's all it takes to migrate
a websphere application running in a vm
to running on kubernetes
there you have it we've successfully
migrated an application from websphere
application server running in a vm
to a container running on gke if you
haven't
already be sure to like and subscribe as
we'll be adding additional videos to the
series
and feel free to check out
migrateforanthos up on google cloud
[Music]
today
you